[Music]
but if you want to make a video but you
just can't afford a camera or what if
you want to make a video right now but
you just don't have access to a camera
or if the world was somehow so cruel and
decided to remove all of my cameras and
ability to record something digitally or
with you I would seriously have to think
outside the box pretty really empty this
mole is any foam happens in three stages
firstly pre-production which is the
basic idea well this week's video was
supposed to be about my sausage dog Joe
called Firefox but we'll get into that
in a bit number two which is production
this is actually going ahead and
shooting it we don't have that one and
then lastly post-production we take the
footage which we don't have and put it
into the air to edit as you can see we
have a slight problem on our hands
that's Joe by the way luckily enough in
the studio have my personal bugs which
weirdly and suspiciously enough is going
to contain all of the objects I need in
order to make a video with the $10
camera of sorts I don't even know if you
can call it a camera and for those who
don't know how a camera works or takes
an image the process of this magical
invention works something like this okay
so a camera is basically a light proof
box built to capture light a camera
works the same way a human eye does the
diagram of the camera is like the iris
of your eye and determines the amount of
light entering the camera behind our
lenses light bands winner travels
through different spaces through
different mediums such as from air to
glass light is then focused to a central
point when you click the shutter button
the moveable mirror shifts are put in
the camera the light stops when it
reaches the foam in the camera or retina
in your eye which forms an inverted
singular image and a video camera
basically does this 24 times a second at
the same speed of human eye processes
movement therefore you have it simple
right
well unfortunately it's not that simple
[Applause]
the only way to truly pull the sofas to
get into the mind of the camera to go
back to basics and couple that with real
life scenes that this foam has some sort
of personal touch to it this is going to
be one difficult task let's pull this
thing
[Music]
this device should capture sufficient
light through this tiny little pinhole
and projector like an image onto the
photography paper at the back I have a
theory that if we capture 24 still
frames we can turn it into a video
therefore I'd need about a thousand of
these photos just to get 40 seconds of
video the idea is simple five barks is a
film about my best friend a 12 year old
sausage dog named Jay the amount of joy
he carries is inspiring he has this
outlandish ability to make anyone laugh
with his mischievous behavior he has
been there through the most important
parts of my life
he has taught me five imperative life
lessons that I will describe visually
through capturing his authentic nature
on different mediums pinhole animation
stop-motion a really unconventional way
without a camera stock footage voiceover
and music
[Music]
we should get a beautiful sunset yeah
I'm gonna try and do some sort of like a
motion blur shot with the I don't know
if it's gonna work
[Music]
stiphu killed in the wind
it's super important to keep this box as
stable as possible and then open up the
shadow for around a minute to let
sufficient lighting - super shaky but
that'll give it them this black bag is
to preserve the capture shooting another
25 images like this is gonna be a night
me now to roughly shoot 900 more don't
even know if we've got anything I'm
gonna do these first shots of German I
try not wake him because I need him to
be stole for the camera he was too
excited so you wake it
[Music]
should you get your Tim forget you there
[Music]
say what sir so plan is to play the
waiting game and wait for joy to go to
bed but between now and when he decides
to go to sleep we can shoot some other
scenes problem is each photo takes so
long about 40 photos in each location
now we wait and then repeat 100 times
just turn the lights off to get the foam
out and for the lights under the lights
going to be a long night off of the
lights I just tweeted imagine earth is
round and people believe that I'm a flat
earth I ridiculous what if the earth is
flat
[Music]
we have to get a lot more tired
[Music]
[Music]
imagine developing all of these it just
blank spoiler alert it was far too dark
in this location and even though we left
the shadow open for the ridiculous
amount of time of 20 minutes they were
still underexposed
oh I can't go to sleep we've got so much
more to shoot are you listening to you
all I need you to do is just lie down on
your couch
maybe he's gay that's the perfect shot I
can see it
I just need Joe to be right yet sleeping
now you stay so I want to sit you I'm
gonna try and do an entire piece of
dialogue in still friend when I say hi
it's gonna be like I'm gonna have to do
like an overdub these are your tools
these are the non-exposed pieces of foam
and this app encouraged it you take a
piece of foil in the dark I can't see I
can't stand repeat if you screw this up
people now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time for the big reveal
hope this work can you turn the light of
white always wisp in the dark do you do
that he's a big bro right can you see me
then that's so sick
show me what it looks like invaded we
used the inverted camera on Luke's phone
to see the true image obvious clearly
please try a little bit and then I'm
gonna move on to scanning them in
inverting them so that I can actually
see what's on the image but from what I
can see it's really dug journeys batches
I'm gonna go look at other mediums like
stocks there's a blanket that you break
and stop-motion this copy machine behind
me is essentially the camera for this
entire production the panel device is
basically the lens if this copy machine
is actually capturing everything for us
since we couldn't make use of a video
camera usually when I make stop motion
we shoot from the top down anyway so I
don't understand how this card will this
is totally gonna work
the animation as well as via three
what's a time three better get moving
I'll quickly dump all the scans and get
to the airport within two hours
I've got all the footage I'm off to the
airport now it's been a long day that
I'll continue when I get to Albania
[Music]
percent dirty a bit cold it's cold I'm
in Volpone Albania in the mountains
called the cursed mountains behind me
over here is a helicopter that
helicopter is gonna be taking as Haiti
covered snowboarding in those mountains
that way but before that which will
probably be next week's video let's
let's start with this this edit BRE this
isn't actually that bad
come check yet can you see it Hey he has
a really quick description of how I got
these images into premiere rush first I
scanned him then inverted them up to
contrast as well as the sharpness try to
lessen the amount of vignetting and then
cut it into a sequence at 12 frames per
second I would also like to add how
seamless workflow is I'm editing well on
the go in Albania on my laptop as well
as my phone I don't know where my phone
is
time to start this mammoth of an edit ok
that's it it took way longer than I
expected
today's my birthday hence why I have
[Applause]
[Music]
I spent way too long in the sickness
menu it's finally exporting enjoy five
box starring Joe boy
who knew a short overweight outlandish
sausage dog could be so wise this is a
firm about his five loudest box always
enjoys the view for an old dog it's
easier to slouch and of course keeping
one's head down offers the opportunity
to find the odd savory scrap but Joe
takes time to wander too
unapologetically observe for the sake of
stillness
[Music]
he moves parties mistakes really quickly
the only real mistake is the one which
he learns nothing from he uses intuition
/ intellect Curtis boy this whisper from
the soul is all he needs to achieve
greatness
he keeps his feets on the ground and
he's head in the sky looking out gives
him the chance to see us looking down at
him always smiling he likes to remind
himself of the fact that he makes us
happy
and he never masks his feelings
and no matter if he jumps up and down
while catching his tail barking 20 times
a day to showcase his excitement to CS
you always do it as if it's his first
not bad right I'm I'm definitely gonna
try and do that again sometime in the
future I will probably not child that
again I just wanna thank Joe for his
incredible participation thank you boy
you were amazing a maze a I want to
collaborate with you therefore make a
foam on rush and hashtag made with rush
and Dan miss and they tweeted to me and
then I will fly to the winner to
collaborate on a film during my season
to make sure to subscribe to my channel
as well as the Adobe Creative Cloud
channel which are linked below it's
super great for reviews and tricks and
tips on editing that I use all the time
other than that
don't forget your awesome route and I'll
see you next week Wednesday